drastic efforts are underway in Cape
Town South Africa to prevent the city
from running out of water the government
declared the crisis a national disaster
on Tuesday water levels behind dams
dropped to dangerous
lows following a three-year drought city
officials say they may be forced to shut
off water taps on June 4th Debora patta
is in Cape Town to show us what's being
done to save four million people from
disaster Debora good morning good
morning it's easy to understand why so
many residents are in denial over the
water restrictions here this is a city
surrounded by spectacular coastline
everywhere you look you see water but
none of it is drinkable four million
people in Cape Town are down to only 13
gallons of water a day compare that to
the average American who uses around 100
gallons a day
the severe restrictions have forced
police to target a new breed of criminal
serial abusers of the city's dwindling
water supplies this lady is breaking the
law you must do it before 90 you cannot
do it off tonight police say the biggest
offenders are often in the most affluent
areas the water restrictions are so
severe there is also a growing market in
illegal water supplies this shop has
been illegally using the city's water
supply purifying it and then selling it
to customers the owner argues with the
police saying all he is doing is trying
to run a business but there are others
who have found innovative ways of
dealing with the restrictions that are
legal like restaurant owner alistair
wilson so are we going 100%
biodegradable and
exactly
already he recycles water from the
melting ice in his bar South African
musicians are also doing their part they
have recorded their hit songs at exactly
2 minutes the maximum time allotted for
a shower when the song is over
so is your shower the water restrictions
are clearly having some effect de xira
has been pushed back by a month that's
the day the city predicts it will run
out of water Gail oh boy that is not a
good situation thank you very much
Deborah Pat in Cape Town it just reminds
us of how much we take water for granted
in this country he turned on a hot you
turn on cold in most cases you can have
as much as you want to walk 2 minutes is
a quick shower very quick hard to get
everything clean in that time I think